[Music]
hey guys I think Oh welcome back to
another episode of trendy versus
traditional where I make trendy
interpretations of your favorite
classics and today repping the
traditional side is my good friend
Ashley oh my god my belly button oh
alright actually what are we making
today today we are making grilled cheese
I'm very excited to be here Ashley told
me that she ate grilled cheese every day
when she was in college I thought that
was between true a nifty DIY Queen she
can make anything out of anything well
maybe not in the kitchen but if there's
one thing that I feel very confident
about it is grilled cheese because I
can't cook anything else that's how I've
become so good at making grilled cheese
my grilled cheese today it's gonna look
a little different than your usual
grilled cheese I'm excited for yours
you're gonna go first okay best of luck
thank you bye bye I need to stay here
okay it's my turn I don't know why I'm
nervous it's not like I haven't made
this I don't know every day for 365 days
so the cheese that I'm using is sharp
cheddar cheese cuz if you're gonna have
cheddar it should just be sharp I like
to use sourdough bread the good kind the
nice fresh kind that's kind of like
crummy when you cut into it I'm gonna
start by grating the cheese cutting the
bread and then we'll get grilling
I feel like when we think of trendy
foods rainbow foods are usually the
first ones we think of and I've been
trying really hard to knock the rainbow
stuff it's so easy to just rainbow
everything and call it a day but what's
really cool is that the og rainbow
grilled cheese actually came from this
store in Hong Kong are called color
toast back in 2016 so it's been a few
years now they actually used natural
food coloring and natural flavoring in
their rainbow grilled cheese the food
coloring I'm gonna be using is this
plant-based food coloring that's pretty
cool to begin with though my cheese I
don't know really the difference between
any of these sides but this one looks
good you can cut it with a knife but I
just think when you grate it it melts
better and easy
and faster because it's already broken
down a little bit I have three types of
cheese here people like to mix it up I
want to get that cool cheese pool that's
why we're going with some mozz and then
over here I have some Gruyere has like a
lower melting point because you want it
super melty you want it super cheesy you
are super gooey oh that looks good
yeah looks Buddha and then over here I
have truffle Gouda you can actually see
like the little specks of black truffle
in there adding some bougie to the mix
there's a little cheese rain going on I
am going to divide them up into four
colors oh I really do love cheese dang I
am also starving while I'm doing this so
I'm hoping it will help me I feel like
my natural instincts are heightened
right now so my senses are going to
hopefully work to my advantage
let's start with the red and I'm
actually gonna start with our tomato
paste to give it that little bit of
tomato flavor add a little bit of our
food coloring now we're gonna go into
yellow the tumeric eyes are really
really strong smell so I don't really
want to go too crazy on it I'm just
adding a little bit let's go into green
I'm gonna chop up some basil I don't
want people to take a bite and then end
up taking a whole leaf out of that
sandwich use them together with a couple
drops oh oh green I just did a blue
foods video where I used a lot of
natural food coloring blue spirulina
extracts which is actually the basis of
this food dye so I'm very excited for
that at college house they actually put
lavender flavoring into their cheese I'm
a little worried that it might turn out
to soapy in mine so I'm not gonna add
any flavoring to the blue so we have our
red our yellow our green and our blue
our cheese is done and here we go we're
ready for liftoff oh that looks good
with that being said it's time to cut
our bread oh that rhymed and this looks
and smells delicious I really like
sourdough normally but today I am using
a fluffy milk bread a thicker piece of
toast too because this looks a little
more like what the original people use
lids cut the bread I always cook for two
because I
end up eating one serving while I'm
cooking and then you got to sit down and
enjoy the meal so you need a second
serving but that's too thick
let's go about there but that feels kind
of thin okay
let's just try you want some ASMR bread
cutting here it is now
squeeze some mayo on and just smear that
gently I think a grilled cheese is
really good when it's really greasy I
don't put butter on the bread before it
goes in the pan
hear me out what I do is I take cooking
spray spray that on the pan it's and let
it get grilled and they last like five
seconds up with the butter on it doesn't
get too greasy one last little and then
we're good now I am going to put my
first slice right on top let it do its
thing first red grilled cheese you can
have too much cheese and a grilled
cheese I know that's gonna make some
people mad but I think you need to have
right proportions to enjoy it I want it
to be so packed that it loses out on to
the side that's when I know it's good
now we're gonna add some yellow look at
how full this is already going before
the green love it and lastly but not
least in the cordon bleu I'm gonna put
the other piece on top and then let her
sit a little you know
now Oh No there's a butter knife yeah
here it is on top almost as if it was
like a pancake or something get it all
over on the edges and everything this is
this ready that's oh I think we're good
here look at this beauty right here oh
oh there she is
this up and while we're cutting we're
gonna listen to this out oh yeah
ready look at how good this looks -
rainbow this I think it needs more
cheese I'm gonna try again
same exact things with a little bit more
cheese if I didn't keep this little pile
for myself it would have been perfect
[Music]
one two three
what are you nearly seeing I see some is
that some now is when we invite our
judge to come in and tell us which one
she prefers she brought tomato soup Wow
more iconic dude now I'm more nervous
I'll do this drum roll oh yeah geez the
bread ratio is ideal let's see how it
goes with my soup
oh okay now for this one I mean just off
looks alone this is really hard to be
you it also just tastes very expensive
in terms of overall experience and how
it matched with my tomato soup I'm gonna
have to say traditional thank you
congratulations
oh my gosh I don't I'm flabbergasted
I'm honored congratulations again thank
you fell back congratulating do a little
cheers yeah I think oh that is so good
I fear this is a winner this is so good
you can't go wrong with a traditional
grilled cheese well thank you guys for
watching this was super super fun I hope
you guys liked the grilled cheese
sandwiches we made let us know which one
you like more in the comments below and
also what else you want to see us to do
next time until then bye
you